hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so in this video guys i
want to make a big analysis on what is
happening on the global market sp y
triple q war between russia and ukraine
guys what can happen we had a crazy week
so let's analyze everything especially
the volume guys and let's see what can
happen next let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so where should we start
spy guys it was crazy all right let's
start on the spy so i was telling you
guys last week that we're gonna have
some acceleration on the downside all
right i didn't even know there would be
a war and especially like that i'm very
shocked guys to be honest i'm french you
know
my mom is actually polish i mean you
know i'm i'm very concerned by this
conflict i think it's really bad but
i mean
i'm here to analyze what is going to
happen on the market and i'm very
surprised to see the market is reacting
so strongly but i told you guys that we
would have an acceleration and once
again this is the beauty of technical
analysis is because you know
we had this event it could have been
something else guys the market needed to
accelerate on the downside it could have
used any excuse here it was this one and
it was a brutal move down now we went
guys here to this level so this is the
waves i kept from last week i mean this
one was here we somehow reached the
target all right the target was 405 for
415 i posted guys on my discord that
on the day of this invasion that 415 is
a level to buy on the spy on triple q i
said 315 guys i personally
had a short position i personally took
uh took profit on my triple q position i
mean s triple q whatever around the
bottom so i was lucky guys because it's
level i had in mind for quite some time
you can look at that guys this is the
trade guys i sent you into this code
here guys all right when you had this
breakout i told you it is going to be an
abc i bought here sold here boot here
sold here you can check guys you can ask
anyone i'm not trying to show you guys
that uh you know what i do is always uh
perfect what i'm only trying to show you
guys is that technical analysis when
used properly is having amazing results
all right and especially on the global
market
so right now i'm gonna try to apply my
methods to this situation i'm back on
the spy guys and i was telling you that
we want to see we have a huge volume
here to know if the 405 415 level
which is an area of support coming from
the past guys as usual many reactions
here is gonna hold or not and i mean i
didn't expect we had something like that
guys okay i expected we arrive with a
red day on the downside so here the
volume is huge but it's a green volume
it's giving me a double information
because the volume is huge which is not
good which is usually saying that the
reversal is not ready to arrive
but it's green which is saying that
bulls are taking back control so i have
mixed signals coming from the volume so
it's very hard to actually have a view
here so for now i'm a bit neutral on
this situation and i'm going to tell you
what i'm going to do to know what to do
next uh but here i'm neutral using this
kind of methods then we have reached the
target once again guys let me go back on
triple q
triple q my target has always been here
guys i'm having this chart for maybe one
month and okay so this 3 17 levels 3 15
we reached
3 18 okay so very close to the target so
maybe
we have reached the bottom i say maybe
because once again when i see a huge
volume like that to me it's it's telling
me that there is a huge fight between
bulls and bears which is not what we
usually see before a reversal before
reversal we usually see a low volume so
mixed signals once again coming from the
volume so what to do now if i use
elliott wave theory it looks like i'm
missing one wave down so maybe we are in
a force that is a bit little bit bigger
than i thought and maybe we're just
gonna drop heavily to 405 this week this
is one scenario if this happened nasdaq
is probably going to go slightly below
the 315 mark so where is the next
support
i mean triple q
next support is around three or seven
all right so in this situation a triple
q could go to three or seven all right
so this is one scenario it's not my
preferred scenario i'm neutral guess for
this week i don't know when i don't know
i will tell you i don't know here i'm 50
50. i don't know what can happen but i
know how to take position before i mean
once we have the information i'm going
to tell you what information i'm looking
for right now so this is one scenario
the second scenario is that we don't
drop we hold here if we hold here where
is the area of resistance look at the
trend lines that are so good guys when
the support is broken it's becoming
resistance so this is the beauty once
again of uh what we do with those trend
lines and here it's 442 something like
that right then we can draw the strand
line so it's purple let's put it in blue
so this trendline is not perfect because
here we have some fake out but it's
still the best one we can have so this
trendline is going to be used here to
know if this move down is complete or
not and this is when the course is going
to be useful guys and i know i'm
repeating that in all the videos but my
course is finally available today guys i
mean two days ago because i'm recording
this video on saturday i'm posting that
on monday morning my course is available
for the past two days and if you want to
have your 50 discount you need to
register to uh by clicking on the link
in the description of this video you're
going to receive a coupon of 50
available only for five more days guys
so do not wait subscribe to that
go visit my website guys i released it
two days ago it's one year of work
between the website the course
everything i'm once again building a
team guys dedicating all my time to make
this place good to transmit the
knowledge i have acquired during my
career guys i enjoy doing that so much i
hope i managed to give you good
information that i'm helping you in your
training because this is really the
purpose of this channel this is the
reason why i quit my job and i'm writing
by the way the article on my website
about this so go read this article it's
going to be interesting and in this
course i'm explaining how to trade
breakouts i'm explaining how to use
volume i'm explaining everything yes so
go take it and you're going to love it
and you're fully refunded if you don't
like it you may think it's expensive but
guys it's a good investment on yourself
trust me so coming back here the reason
why i said that is because once again
guys as usual we're going to be looking
for a breakout so
if this breakout is going to be good
quality we're going to have at some
point there's going to be consideration
i don't know yet if it's going to be
below 44 to maybe here or below this
trend line
like that okay
but we're going to have a consolidation
somewhere then once we have the
consideration we know where are the
sellers we know where is the liquidity
area we know where the stop losses we
then know what information we're looking
for we're looking for a breakout above
this consolidation area so let's say
it's going to be here then if you have a
breakout here guys wheeze volume
increase and here i want to see this
volume decrease in the consolidation
then break out
then guys we're gonna be bullish and
then probably we're gonna go much higher
so those are my two scenarios i don't
see that okay i don't see a strong move
up without stopping guys because you
look at the situation it's too bad for
the market to just be bullish bullish
bullish if we do something like that
then we're gonna pull back strongly and
still be able to buy around this levels
so buying on the way up is not the good
approach here but on the way down we can
drop heavily right the market is not
symmetric uh when we it comes to go up
and down i mean in the way it it makes
the moves so first scenario i repeat
guys how do we move lower maybe sharply
fan support around four five then
rebound okay then here we're gonna try
to find a breakout the same way or we
stay around this level consolidate
somewhere i'm not sure where exactly
then identify the liquidity area and
identify when
a breakout would be good quality and use
the breakout signal to enter and play
the move up okay guys so this is my
scenario i don't know where is the
resistance yet on the upside i will let
you know in my next video once i see it
on the nasdaq the levels are pretty much
the same so on the downside 307 320
let's say all right this range is a
buying area if you see the price action
coming here i mean no financial advice
but i would personally be a buyer then
on the upside i don't have any real
resistance i would say 350 is the major
resistance so maybe a consolidation here
we have this trend line as well that is
coming guys
okay so it can be used as well to find a
breakout so let's see we same thing as
we're looking for consolidation to then
play the breakout so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore see
you guys